Our database will contain
weather forecast entries.
Our data model will use two tables:
One table will be used
to contain information about the location,
while the other will contain
the forecast data key to the locations.
These will ultimately be tied back
to our view through the contract,
and the content provider.
We can use an inner join, to pull
the complete data for each forecast today,
including all information about the location.
This, is a big contract.
Note that we store the location ID,
which will be a foreign key
from the location table
in COLUMNLOCKEY.
Note that the units aren't stored
in the database.
We expect all weather entries
to be stored in metric units,
and converted when needed
by the UI, into imperial units.
Since the column names
don't actually contain data types,
it's useful to annotate that
in the variable names
and/or the comments
to make our contract more explicit.